so the democrats have all been
pretending that they're poor
am not just talking about the regular
democrats I'm talking about the power
people
Hillary Clinton and Joe Biden in
particular Hillary
of course is going to run in 2016 by 10
may run which i think would kinda be
fine in the Naked Gun way but also kinda
scary
so we did this in two weeks ago Hillary
talking about how poor
she is and she was as we've got two
clips on her
and wanna bite into it let's watch
Hillary talking about her struggles
it has been reported you've made five
million
making speeches the president made more
than 100
million dollars well if
if you you have no reason to remember
but we came out at the white house
not only dead broke but in dept we had
no
money when we got there and we struggle
to
you know piece together the resources
for mortgages for houses for
childhood education you know it was not
easy
okay that under nine cents and total
bullshit so
basically she saying we came in with
nothing not true I mean they
add money he was the governor of
arkansas bill
and then they left could never be needin
money
for houses houses how many houses do you
that some pretty sure they're doing ok
am pretty sure there's no restaurant
that they've ever been that turned away
from but she continued
first but we had to pay off our debts
which was
you know you had to admit double the
money because I've obviously taxes and
pay off the debts and
guest houses and take care of family
members but do you think americans can
understand five times
the median income in this country for
months
speech well let me put it this way I
thought
making speeches for money was a much
better thing than getting connected with
any
one group or company as so many people
who leave public life do
because she's so much better than those
people who take money from one
she did take four hundred thousand did
you can speeches from Goldman Sachs
and I'm not regretting her any this
you're allowed to make money this is
america that's great
but don't pretend that you have no money
nor access to making money in the future
and then job I'd in here we go the first
to review this season by
he's got Hugo made my only expensive
suit on
%uh his vice president on stage
American he makes not withstand these
nurses
force many congress he still makes a lot
of money as well as present I station I
do much way
don't hold it against me they are that I
don't own a single stocker behind
don't own I have no savings account but
I got a great pension I enhance our
and Ohio mean I'm telling you his
presidency would be Frank Drebin from a
guy
okay he is black outlying he does have a
savings account
and he does have 11 investment Bynes
there in his wife's name so yes
technically I suppose he's not lying but
he's lying
so where owners are this I don't
begrudge these guys success
I want people to be running the country
that know how to
do their finances so hopefully they can
help the finances of the country
what is the fascination with pretending
they're poor
and struggling want to relate to the
american people because
you know the feeling that can help them
get elected in you know increase their
approval ratings and stuff but
I don't understand why so hard to be
like I wasn't always as successful but
now I've done better
Hazarika said I know that she was being
asked questions like have you ever
situation a little bit differently
yeah i buy and his bride is just me no
one's asking him anything he's just like
I don't have a savings account
then I mean it's just kind of like
ridiculous like you said to fight a lot
why can't they
you know be honest and say you know I
can relate because I was once in that
position you now have come out of that
but
to fit their livestock to help right now
by did say one thing that was true which
is that he was when he was in the senate
he was the poorest member
I it in terms of having money in the
senate
but that like what so he blatantly lies
there
what should we do about II a politician
like a cable
on call their asses outlet don't like
what you doing I mean this is
in there they overreacted just like
unless they're all feeling raped by the
paparazzi in groups feel in lecture that
war
this is the art and and generally to the
american people and it's completely
backfiring and by the way I made an
impression and Diane Sawyer in that clip
which is this
the she looks like she's not a slap the
shit out and Hillary
because she's sitting here thinking
you've got to be kidding me I know what
my salary is and yours is definitely
higher
and yes he has to pay for 10 you
and her daughter's education I believe
family expenses and their
the how easy is how their by the way you
know jewelry
chelsea clinton was also at you know
just a couple years ago two years ago
given a 600,000 your job at NBC News
despite the fact that he was a qualified
always pretty
terrible they basically paid her to do
like three appearances so
so that's pretty sweet why do we have
success shame
do you think that's what it seems to me
i get if they wanna relate everybody but
we seem
to have this real thing where were
shamed love
wanting to be successful or actually
being successful I'm going to carry over
from the last election I think they were
so
Romney got so much flak for presumably
prison
is that where the word is having so much
money that he lost the election he was
seen as
unrelated bone out of touch and we know
what to heathers credit
you know like at the end of the month
guys when I keep Pagerank you pay the
bills were waiting for like the checks
to come in
that's when your account is kinda influx
our bet you know and then with the
clintons
I'll bet you you know their accounts are
in flux by millions and millions of
dollars and there's always that one day
in the month where might be negative 10
million like hillary talked about
but of course she has yet to cash the
rest in the check and so she's trying to
relates with just that
all got the 30th and every month I just
%uh like they're ok
I think you're BC that's probably it
there is probably some truth to that
they had right yet
by the way her campaign which in 2008
ran into debt
you she had owners pay off for campaigns
dead sold some you don t shirts
really seventy by newer hi they were up
there especially after she lost because
they were
collector's items yeah juniors um so the
reason I'm doing this segment is because
it seems to me that we're always
attacking republicans about money but i
wanna go to know that the democrats are
just
as bad do you think that's affair
estimation
do you think it's fair I mean I feel
like they're trying too hard to be
reliable because they feel like that so
important
but to be ashamed of success is really
ridiculous I think the reason why do not
is because people
you know make them in a position where
being successful could be viewed as a
negative trait in a politician because
I'll
will never be able to relate to me
because they have all this money I'm
struggling financially while they try
to go either way to help me ray if they
can't relate more
butterfly to lives and helping and for
people to even
have that attitude in society that
success is a negative thing
is ridiculous I can't think hundreds and
hundreds of politicians who are
a contradiction to that I mean no one
thinks that the senate where the shots
are presented as all these people who
are making
a shit ton of money and no one ever says
anything about them because all they can
see are the president the vice-president
these people were so much
in the public eye but they're not the
only people in politics and not the only
people
making a lot of money and george bush W
Bush he had a ton of money
yeah I would has connections to oil and
stuff and no one ever
complaint about that because they're
like all Texas and not going to relate
to people
claim the Democrats plan yeah it's
pretty much an idiot and no one care
a lot people whenever he's being elected
in the air because they're like
he so relatable to you know Texas and
right here highly contentious like a guy
any knew that throw a baseball remember
he threw that first pitch advanced right
to being a president but any motel
all most people who reach the level of
education you would hope that they would
have in order to be
holding public office like that they're
gonna be in a position where they're
making money because they've reached a
level of success
other people have it break would you
rather have someone in office who has no
idea how to handle their personal
finances and is it in debt
you need if you knew that the guy that
was coming in the present you really
fucked up
his financial situation you know you
mean he's got creditors calling here
that's what they somehow want this
that's what she saying like I we were in
all
we had not been but I would never want
that person to be president right it's
sad that think that that's
the related will candidate though they
like a we must you know reach out to the
millions of Americans who are in debt
and have hunters chase after them in
order to get there about
yeah tragic unless thought on this the
line just the flat out lying which is
what they're both doing I get hillary's
doing it a little bit less
because she sorta mincing words may be
dead whatever
but he's flat-out lie because it's his
wife that owns the stuff and that's a
lie
so does that matter even does anyone
even care when they get caught
the subway yet I mean I don't know how
much he cares that he should
yeah as I mean at least for me I'm not
gonna try somebody you know how many
people trust politicians
yeah but I mean for him to sit there and
say you know it's my wife's money not
mine I mean look at me I was up there
have a savings account
ridiculous yeah the lying matter do you
really just expected
I I think it comes with the territory
unfortunately I think in their gonna
passing of as you know be just
politics tonight they told they told a
little bit ima fairburn there they'd
years on the dinner party conversation
we just say something to relate to the
person next to you just to make them
feel little bit better
and I don't honestly think it's going to
hurt them whatsoever their charming
personality and celebrity status is
going to get them to the next level
yeah well sadly I agree with you they
have more money than you which is OK
but you know what they're liars about
the mod alright